you think that patri puts as much value
in the process of making something in
the final product I mean nobody does
nobody cares about anymore unless
there's so much going on with it and the
collectors oh collectors really my show
has been up for weeks and you managed
one sale but this guy who I've never
seen
before he's got collectors lined up
Grace uh can you give me a second sorry
is he your next show is he on the roster
are you on the roster you want to take
oh my God are you the
bagman oh sorry do you think that
everyone doesn't know about the bagman
because lesle was telling everybody at
the gr pillar opening about him sorry
so you're the bagman what do you know
about a bagman I really got to deal with
this deal with this oh I'm so sorry Pat
I had no idea my career was such a
goddamn inconvenience to you you know
what you hey chill out
whoa what
let's have this conversation
later you just
want Grace you're a straight white man
making boring a straight white man art
you are making a killing in the art
World by making safely abstract wall
decor 150,000 for your first
Beast belongs is the holiday
in
now